uh i'm happy to have uh introduced
superbrodassen of harvard for the first
talk of the morning
and he'll tell us about principles of
matrix recovery
um thanks so much ryan let me just
share my screen
okay does that look good
okay um so thanks so much to the
organizers for the wonderful workshop
thanks so much for the invitation to
speak we've had some really wonderful
talks so far um so today i want to talk
about
the overlap gap property for submatrix
recovery
um this is based on joint work with uh
david gomarnik and now
so the premise for this talk is sort of
in in these statistical versus
computational tradeoffs we have heard a
lot about this
uh so far in this workshop um
you know there has been accumulating
evidence that there are sort of quite a
few high-dimensional statistics problems
where sort of optimal statistical
inference might be
impossible to do using computationally
feasible methods and certain regimes of
the parameter space
and evidence for this has been provided
using very very different techniques
such as you know average case reductions
analysis of a and p type algorithms sum
of squared lower bounds
and so on so forth we have heard about
quite a few of these approaches so far
um in contrast to that i want to talk
about some structural evidence
um for hardness in the average case
um so i'll talk about a very specific
problem
which is related to planted submatrix
recovery
and uh we'll see what the structural
evidence
actually gives us formally in terms of
hardness for specific algorithms but in
general i think this approach is
intuitive and sort of useful because it
kind of suggests
why it might be difficult to solve this
problem at least with certain classes of
algorithms
okay so i'll talk about um principles of
matrix recovery um
so the setting is that we we get to see
an n by n
um symmetric matrix most of the entries
of this matrix
are gaussian with mean 0 however there
is a hidden
planted sub matrix where the mean has
been elevated
to be lambda over n and and i'll talk
about a setting where the size of this
planted sub matrix is
n rho by n rho and
uh the background gaussians have been
scaled so that um the spectral norms of
the
uh planted matrix and the background
noise are on the same scale
and um of course
this problem sort of exhibits slightly
different behavior
depending on the size of the planted sub
matrix so today i'll look at a very
specific regime
where the size of the planted submatrix
is actually
linear in the size of the ambient matrix
but the leading constant is very tiny so
i'll sort of formally look at a double
asymptotic regime where first the size
n tends to infinity and then row goes to
zero okay
um so this sort of uh i think is useful
to think of in terms of problems such as
sparse pca
um i think we'll hear uh from elias a
bit more about
the setting in the next talk
so given this general setting um
there are certain questions that are of
natural interest
so the first and basic question is if i
give you this matrix can you detect the
presence of this
planted submatrix so can you tell me
whether this is just
plain noise or whether there is some
signal or not
and then if you can actually distinguish
this
matrix from pure noise the question
naturally becomes
okay can you actually recover the
submatrix and
naturally here we will also ask the
question can we actually recover it
efficiently
so one point that i actually want to
emphasize here is that the corresponding
detection question
in this particular setting is actually
trivial this is because if you just
sum the entries of the matrix in this
regime it is very easy to see that the
sum based statistic will distinguish
between
the null that lambda is 0 versus the
alternative that lambda is positive for
any lambda
okay and then i just wanted to make this
point because
we've heard quite a few talks so far in
this workshop where
even the detection question is hard so
this is sort of
a slightly different problem in that
detection is actually fairly easy
but estimation is somehow hard okay
so today we'll basically focus on the
second two questions right how well can
we recover this planted submatrix
and can this be recovered efficiently
now let me spend a few moments
describing the history of this problem
so a bayesian version of this problem
where the
so you know my matrix can be represented
as a one rank spike
of a goe matrix so one natural
uh bayesian formulation is where the
entries of the spike are iid from a
certain distribution
so back in 2014 uh deshpande and
montanari they initiated a study of this
setting where the entries
of the spike were iid bernoulli with
probability rho
they analyzed the behavior of the bayes
optimal a and p
and they concluded that there is some
critical uh
density rho such that if rho is bigger
than this row critical
then amp-based algorithms will perform
base optimal uh inference in this
problem
um this was followed up on uh in
subsequent works
uh by lesser atoll uh they actually
started
exploring this acid this double
asymptotic where first n goes to
infinity and then rho goes to zero
and they based on the analysis of the
state evolution system that arises from
amp-based algorithms they concluded that
there should be a hard phase in this
problem
in this scaling um
i should also remark that um on on the
theoretical statistics end there has
been a lot of exploration about
submatrix recovery per se
and people have figured out the
information theoretic limits as well as
sort of
computational barriers and stuff but one
crucial difference
from what we will be looking at today is
that
on the statistics side the question has
usually been about
exact recovery so this is usually
referred to as the sub matrix
localization problem
and that has sort of a substantial
literature on its own right
but these two i mean our results are not
directly comparable with theirs because
our metrics will be slightly different
okay so
what will we be doing today so we want
to look at this problem and i want to
provide
you some rigorous evidence based on the
characteristics of the problem that
inference might be hard in certain
settings
now to do that i will be looking at the
behavior of the maximum likelihood
estimator in this setting
um and then i'm happy to talk about you
know whether
the mle is the best thing to do in this
setting or not but i think even this
will provide us with some good intuition
so the maximum likelihood in this
problem
basically reduces to this discrete
optimization problem where we seek to
maximize this quadratic form
in the matrix m m is the matrix that we
have observed
subject to these constraints so the
vector x is a binary vector and it has
exactly n row many elements that are 1.
this encodes the fact that i'm looking
for n row by n rows of matrices
and our metric for our estimators is is
what we refer to as
proximate recovery so the point is can
we recover a linear proportion of the
hidden support
right so you should think of the
constant c here as some universal
constant like 0.1
or 0.5 so you want to recover some fixed
proportion
and this c is independent of both n and
rho
okay um so our first result
uh is of an information theoretic nature
and it identifies uh the signal strength
that you need for approximate recovery
right so
it first says that um sorry
so it first says that if lambda is
actually little o
of a square root 1 over rho log 1 over
rho then approximate recovery is
impossible
on the other hand if lambda is bigger
than 2 square root 1 on row log 1 on row
then
the maximum likelihood estimate actually
performs approximate recovery
right so this identifies the information
theoretic threshold that one
needs for this process
um however you know
if you go back and look at our maximum
likelihood problem you see that okay
this is a discrete optimization problem
as such we don't quite know of you know
a natural way to do this
efficiently so you might say okay
what are simple algorithms that i can
use and
a simple algorithm would be a naive
spectral algorithm that
would basically look at the top
eigenvector of this matrix
and round its entries uh suitably to
construct
a binary vector with exactly n row many
ones okay
and it's this is definitely you know
very easy to see just using properties
of
gaussian random matrices that you need
lambda to be bigger than one over rho
for the naive spectral algorithm to work
okay so note that one over rho when rho
is small is actually
much bigger than the square root one
over rho
threshold that you need for mle to work
and so this brings us to sort of this
natural question
[Music]
what happens for intermediate signal
strengths lambda
right um
so to explore sort of what happens there
um
i'd like to look at sort of a restricted
version of the likelihood
okay so what this does is that
it maximizes the likelihood subject to
an additional constraint
that i actually have a fixed n times q
overlap with the underlying truth so in
terms of matrices
you should think that okay i have my
plant it's a matrix and i'm specifying
that i
will maximize my likelihood subject to a
certain number of rows and columns
that i will have in common with the
planted truth
now one point of course to note is that
this is of course a theoretical
construct
we will study this to understand
properties of the problem
and this is not something that we can
compute given the data
right okay
so one of our main technical results
is is to conclude that this restricted
likelihood function for every value of q
actually converges to a deterministic
limit uh
this deterministic limit is phrased in
terms of uh for easy type formulae we
will come back to this in a bit
so this is some you know fairly involved
formula but it's explicit at least
right and we know that this is sort of a
deterministic formula
in the limit where n tends to infinity
now how let's try to see what sort of
intuition we can gain by actually
looking at the properties of this
function e
um to develop some intuition let's say
i actually plot this function e as a
function of q
for different values of lambda right
okay so what will happen
let's think of a simple case first so if
lambda is 0
this is the case where i have no signal
and therefore it's all
impossible to detect the planted matrix
and so i will expect my function e to
basically
be unimodal and have its maximum at rho
squared right this is the
sort of random overlap point and then
we'll have sort of a maximum there
on the other hand if lambda is very very
large
what will happen is that this function
will still be unimodal
but the maximum will shift and
the maximum will actually be attained at
some constant times rho
okay this is the regime where the mle
actually will perform approximate
recovery
and and sort of at least in this regime
it is suggestive that you know if i
start
any local algorithm and if i initialize
it at random
i will start at somewhere near rho
squared and so it is suggestive that
maybe we'll be able to climb this hill
and get to the top
um the main sort of
takeaway is that we can formally prove
that there is sort of this intermediate
signal regime where lambda is sort of
one over rho to the half plus alpha for
some alpha sufficiently small
where this restricted likelihood
function has this non-monotonic property
okay and the reason you know why we call
this
a version of overlap gap is that
if you look at sort of configurations
of submatrices that have likelihood
values beyond a certain level
then um you know it's overlapped with
the planted truth
could could either be very large or be
very small
and actually we have sort of a gap in
the middle this is the sort of
set of overlaps that cannot be attained
so in this sense this is sort of a
version of overlap gap
and one point to emphasize here is that
in contrast to
sort of unplanted problems here we look
at an overlap with the planted truth
rather than overlaps between two iib
samples
okay so right
um as
a formal consequence of our results
um what we can prove is that a simple
family of local markov chains
will not be able to perform approximate
recovery in this regime
of signal to noise ratio so
one natural thing to do is that if you
want to maximize the quadratic form
you run a markov chain which has
stationary distribution
you know a gibbs type distribution
corresponding to beta where beta is very
large
um and the formal result here
let me not parse the entire thing um you
know instead
but the the take away message is that if
you are initialized sort of near rho
squared so at random
and if you run this local dynamics then
it takes you
exponential time to sort of escape the
local maximum near rho squared
and sort of get to the global one
okay um so
let me pause for a second here to see if
there are questions
regarding sort of our main results and
sort of the main takeaways
okay okay so
in in sort of the time that i have left
maybe i can talk a bit about um
the sort of some proof ideas and and
highlight sort of
how we went about doing this so as i
said the main
technical um sort of ingredient was up
for easy type formula for this
restricted likelihood function
um and then sort of one had to actually
analyze the behavior of this variational
formula
in the scaling limit where rho goes to
zero right
our proofs for the information theoretic
result
i think are sort of more standard and
they use
relatively straightforward information
theoretic techniques
uh initially we only had this result the
negative result for the mle but
one of our referees pointed out a very
clever
improvement that so that we can now rule
out other estimators as well
um but let me actually
uh talk about the the overlap gap
analysis
in this context um so the relevant
for easy formula that arises uh is the
following sorry there's a lot of text
here so let me go over this slowly
so the first simplification of course is
that
without loss of generality we can assume
that the planted matrix is sort of at
the top
and left corner right this doesn't
change the problem at all
um the in this case we will
end up with a variational problem on an
infinite space
corresponding to parts that are
non-decreasing these also came up in
ahmed stock
a few days ago so the variational
parameter here at least one of the
variational parameters here
will be a function m which is
non-decreasing
um and then we'll sort of it's easier to
phrase it in terms of a measure nu
which has a density that is m and lambda
1 and lambda 2 sort of are two real
numbers these are two lagrange
parameters that actually enforce the
constraints
that there are exactly n row many ones
and sort of mq many ones that are
overlapping with the planted truth
okay and so the eventual parisi formula
here
sort of is uh so you have sort of two
for easy type terms that come up
these are solutions of these non-linear
pdes
started from this final time
configuration
and as i mentioned before lambda 1 and
lambda 2 are my lagrange parameters
right
the final form for the
restricted ground state energy in
physics terms and the restricted
likelihood in a more statistical
terminology
is sort of a lambda q squared this is
sort of the overlap
contribution that you have to your
energy from the planted truth
and then sort of the noise contribution
okay now
to analyze sort of the overlap gap um
formally what we do is that you know we
directly analyze this restricted energy
so we take a derivative in q um you get
sort of a linear term which
increases and then the main complicated
term to analyze arises in terms of the
difference between these two lagrange
multipliers so technically
the main challenge is to analyze their
behavior
for different values of q in the limit
when rho goes to zero
okay um and and formally
uh this is sort of what we actually
establish um
to show overlap gap right so we show
that at rho squared this derivative is
positive
there is some point which is little low
of rho where this derivative is negative
so we
know there is some point uh which
dominates both of these
in the middle and then in the
signal-to-noise ratio regime where you
know lambda is like one over rho to the
half plus alpha
uh the maximum is actually attained
beyond the point q2
right so that that suffices for us and
uh
i'd like just like to add that
you know the main difficulty that arises
from analyzing this lambda 2 and lambda
1
um what we can do here is that
our main idea is to utilize sort of
recent advances in the study of
mean field spin glasses and per easy
type variational problem
and and there um a natural diffusion
that comes up
uh is related sort of i mean this is a
diffusion that has a brownian component
and a drift which is given by
the first derivative of the function in
itself this also came up in our med
stock and and
these lagrange multipliers are
characterized as fixed point equations
in terms of this sde
so for example you know just to give you
a flavor of this analysis
if your first term were absent so for
example if
if these diffusions were just brownian
motions then you could exactly
identify these lambda i stars in terms
of the quantiles of a gaussian
distribution
and you could directly analyze their
behavior for different values of
q the main difficulty that arises is
that we don't really know how the drift
term behaves and we have to be a bit
hacky about it and that sort of um
gives us whatever we can prove um so let
me
emphasize one point here is that you
know our results related to overlap gap
that i emphasized i mean we can prove
this only for alpha sufficiently small
i think evidence that arises from low
degree likelihood based
methods that elias will present i think
right after this
they suggest that actually the threshold
the computational threshold should be at
one over row
where our spectral algorithm works so i
think it would be really interesting if
we could prove
the existence of overlap gap up to
one over rho at this point we can prove
it
maybe up to one over rho to the point
six
and and the main barrier that we have
been facing so far is that
we don't really have a very good way to
exactly analyze these lambda i stars
so if one could do this analysis a bit
more accurately
this would probably improve the bounce
and i actually believe that
it should be able to prove that the ogp
persists up to one over row but
so far we don't really have that
so following our results uh there has
been actually quite some progress on
this problem so
the actual mutual information in the
related bayesian version of the problem
when uh rho is actually converging to
zero with
n that has been worked out um in a set
of papers by
jean barbier and his collaborators using
uh the adaptive interpolation method um
so gerard alex and elias
have actually extended some of this
analysis to the case where
rho actually converges to zero i think
elias will talk at length about this in
the next
talk and there has been a very recent
paper by
uh salil and alex where they actually
established estimation lower bounds in
this context using the load
degree likelihood methods and stuff so i
think that's also very interesting
um and yeah i think sort of these
results have added
additional perspectives to this problem
um
so let me finish here thanks so much for
your attention let me know if there are
questions
thank you vibrato
[Applause]
thank you uh
great so uh time to quiz superbroda who
has some questions for him
on that talk
maybe go ahead go get going i have a
question uh
related to the definition of those
lagrange multipliers the stationary
conditions
um yeah in this slide so the last line
i can't parse the last line um
so is that an expectation or like
there's something missing
oh sorry sorry sorry yeah that's a typo
thanks ahmed uh i
i wanted to say that i want these
probabilities
uh that i think these are bigger than
equal to zero
bigger than okay started at zero and
does that define the
does that tell you the law of these
lambda stars or i mean i guess the value
of those lambda stars
yeah because because all i want so if
you think about it if you knew this
exact solution right then these are
diffusions
so you want a corresponding quantile of
that diffusion right so it's a random
variable you want it
it identifies the lambda eyes in terms
of the law i see you're pointing out the
text
yeah thanks yeah uh i believe sam has a
question for you
hey superbada uh hey can you say
a little bit about a little more about
what kind of algorithms this rules out
so you said something about local
markov chains but like sometimes these
kinds of results my understanding is
that they really only rule
can understand what happens when you
initialize
in some kind of very funny way like the
mark like the gibbs measure conditioned
on low overlap
yeah random initialization and that
that's there
uh yeah i i kind of skipped over that
but that's uh that's a very fair point
so what this can formally rule out
is a local markov chains that are
started from the gibbs distribution
um initialized at rho squared overlap
um i think the point is that okay from a
physics perspective i guess it would be
natural to believe that that would look
like
an iid initialization but sure
that's that's not really formal and in
general i think
one question that i think is is very
important to answer is sort of whether
these structural results actually imply
barriers for
other classes of algorithms as well i
think if if one could prove
this in more generality then it would be
definitely something more
you know more important and interesting
what is the meaning of local here
so local here is just in the sense that
uh if you do a markov chain on the state
space
of bernoulli vectors with exactly n row
many ones
and it's it's exactly two configurations
are local if they differ at exactly two
locations right so you move
one bit out here and put it somewhere
else okay the point is as long as as
long as the moves
the individual moves are bounded in
hamming distance
yeah and the markov chain has to be
something that would can like it has to
be
some kind of global dynamics e thing
or or it just has to be something who's
whose stationary distribution is gibbs
yeah that that will work anything with
stationarity okay cool yeah
maybe one question well um
so so rather you mention i mean one
benefit i guess so the scaling regime
that you're considering is that you
obtain this partisan type of formulas
right
right and i was thinking you know like
it's a general question of how like the
overlapping property like you're
considering
relates in any way to this replica
symmetry breaking
in the par easy measure and i was
thinking like is there
do you do you get any information about
the maximizers or the minimizers or is
this
like you know of the parties and do they
have any funny behavior
like is there anything you understand
about these things um so
let me try to understand the question is
the question is that okay
this sort of overlap gap that we have
does it actually in turn say something
about the minimizers of the
exactly because we are kind of expecting
this right in the non-pla
unplanned case at least
like the if you get because you know
usually in the regimes i have considered
there are no such participants so i mean
that's right right so i mean i mean yeah
so in general
you know technically this is sort of one
of the big challenges
is because if you study the maximum
likelihood you expect this problem to be
sort of fully replicatory breaking and
you need the entire easy machinery
but whether this in turn yields sort of
real insights into the behavior of the
easy minimizers
i don't quite know yeah
yeah i i wouldn't i i don't immediately
see
whether it adds something but yeah i
guess if someone else
sees something and they would like to
add something that would be great okay
thank you very much
superbroda there's a question from j
martia jay are you able to
uh say your question aloud yeah uh
basically i i was asking
whether like are there other structural
properties that are different from like
studying the overlap of solutions that
people also
look at in these contexts and that give
anything interesting
right so that i think is is sort of very
interesting
and relevant right so i think the reason
why overlaps
were initially studied is that it became
quite clear that this overlap gap
property appears in many unplanted
problems so if you look at
random optimization problems then it
comes up in many hard optimization
problems and and there is
a lot of very interesting work by david
and his collaborators and many other
people
where they have established that in
random optimization problems
if you have the overlap gap property
between two approximately optimal
solutions then that can be used to rule
out
a large family of local algorithms
now in our context of course we are
looking at sort of a planted problem so
one can naturally raise this question
that okay this notion of overlap that
you look at
is this naturally the best thing to do
at this point all i can say is that well
once we have this this does rule out
some families of markov chains
but i think the question may be that
you're raising is that there might be
some other structural property that
actually points to a barrier to other
algorithms and i think
such a thing would definitely be very
interesting to look at but
as far as i know i don't quite know of
other genetic things that people have
looked
at thanks
one follow-up to that is there is the
paper by uh
alex and gerard and
david i'm not sure the exact author list
that relates the overlap gap in random
optimization
problems to behavior of low degree
polynomials so you could call behavior
of low degree polynomials
yeah that's i guess by david akash and
and alex sorry yeah uh yeah but
the crucial difference i think is that
still in the context of unplanted
problems
so i think the the issue is but you
might believe
it it's believable right there would be
a nice open problem to see whether
overlap
gaps in planted problems are related to
um
behavior of low degree moments yeah no
that that i think is definitely an
interesting question
or even better if it's related to other
algorithms you know context programs or
something
yeah yeah yeah sure anything in addition
to this like
in in regression maybe a comment on this
in regression we kind of use
the techniques for the overlander to
rule out certain convex
programs but we never were able for
example to direct things
which is uh which would benefit right so
i i i think the point is
i mean sort of as far as i know the the
only cases where
the the ogp has been examined in the
context of planted problems isn't the
sort of results that
uh alias and david had on regression and
then sort of we had in the context of
planted submatrices
and then there has been examination here
but
so far the these results themselves have
not been
you know useful to prove barriers
directly the techniques have been useful
but
i thought also for for tensor pca don't
i'll caution results
right right that's that's very important
yes i missed that so akash
raza and gerard has the results of pca
as well
let's see anybody have any further
questions for superbrada
well since since we mentioned tensorbc
let me follow up and ask if the
following is open is it still would it
be open to establish it
for the error problem from computer
science perspective which is random
sat or random planted xor or something
like that
like the the sparse analog of tensor pca
yeah so i i don't know actually ogp
in the planted context on sparse
problems so i think that's still open as
far as i know
i think there is something like in the
conversation phase transition that has
been kind of proven
that it's kind of similar i think in
some way from a meme
i think but um yeah i think it's kind of
established i'm not sure what the
implications are really
they're more like on the shuttering for
sad that you know we believe
it it implies a hard reason but i don't
think we know a formal
implication even for markov that's for
the shattering stuff is this is for
planted sat or for a total for a random
sat
so it is it is i mean i i think the
i mean it's definitely for the
non-planted case but
yeah that's that's what i meant yeah
so for the unplugged case it's
definitely there i guess the question
sam was playing remember
yeah yeah i'm pointing to the you know
refutation of random
random xor or you know recovering
planted solutions or whatever yeah maybe
take it back maybe i don't know
um so at least for the stochastic block
model we know like the free energy
uh landscape pretty well for the planted
case but we had the same problem of what
was the starting position of the markov
chain
we wanted to start random and prove that
there's slow mixing but we
couldn't do that i think sam we even
talked about this way back yeah we
talked about this way back in
santa fe yeah yeah so that was where we
were stuck that you would
like to say start from a natural
position and get slow mixing
we see the energy barriers but that
doesn't actually tell you from a natural
starting point
is slow mixing really what matters
though i mean if it's okay if mixing is
slow if you get somewhere close to the
planted assignment
right i mean but you won't even get the
the barriers are like
separating you from anything overlapping
okay yeah in that case right yeah yeah
chris we talked about this as well
yeah i guess sorry yeah it's like
for how many communities will do you
have such a free energy barrier
what do you say i guess like four or
more
in the this is so disassortative case
actually that's
it okay yeah we don't we don't know how
to do it and assorted
there's a question from matthew brennan
matthew can you ask a question
yeah so this is just a general question
going back to tensor pca
so with tensor pca like the ogp
is it right that it's conjectured or
maybe proven already to hold
above the algorithmic limit of um tensor
pca like local algorithms are much worse
than like the spectral one
do you know like so like for this
problem for sub-matrix recovery
it seems like you were saying that you
expected the ogp to go up to exactly the
algorithmic barrier even though it's not
proven
okay do you know what problems in
general for which like when can you
decide whether or not a problem is going
to have like ogp matching the
algorithmic threshold
right i think that that's also very
relevant right so i think okay
so i think matt's question i'll try to
answer it in the context of
the specific problem because i don't
recall the exact
thresholds in the context of tensor pca
so what i
remarked is that i definitely believe
that in this problem
it would be natural to believe that you
would have ogp persisting
up to lambda going to one over rho but i
think the question matt is raising is it
is possible in principle that it just
persists beyond that
and that would indicate that spectral
algorithms are just better than sort of
local algorithms
in this particular problem i think that
is possible
i don't quite know whether that is the
case in this setting
in the context of tensor pca
i'm not sure whether the known
thresholds are
um already proved that you that spectral
type things are better i think
uh the results are by bernaro's gesari
and jagannath
but i i don't know the precise
thresholds that they have
maybe i can i can say something about
this if uh
like i think i think it's actually i
think matt's point is correct like
we like the work of uh of focus and
serrano
like kind of proves that there is a free
energy well like not exactly overlapping
property but something similar
like a local barrier above the algorithm
indeed so like even even beyond this and
something we saw with david in the
planet click is like
indeed like at least the normal
landscape has local buyers barriers
above the square root
so i think at least normal like i i can
say more maybe i will wait for it a
little bit in my talk on this but i
think we
we kind of expect that like there could
be overlapping property beyond
for some such other examination problems
yeah and
okay but uh yeah i mean that's fair to
be fair
yeah sorry just one follow-up question
so like is it possible that this is
somewhat related to whether or not the
problem sparse
like i like when i hear random 3x or for
example i often think that that's the
same as tensor pca
but also like at the same time it's kind
of like a sparse problem like random
threesat where you'd expect local
algorithms to be maybe
close to optimal is it possible that
like random 3xor
might not have this weird property that
you can prove ogp above the algorithmic
error
even though pca does like i don't know
this is maybe a very
vague question so i i guess you're
wondering if
if the nature of the problem on the
sparse graph versus
the dense model can be really different
yeah
yeah for the ogp even though the
algorithmic barriers are like
analogous
my prediction would be that it's not
it's not really the sparsity but it's
more the additivity of the noise
like i feel that like it's the for
example the pca structure that you add
the noise or the planet click that kind
of add noise
because in regression we didn't really
see this phenomenon or like uh you know
that was more of a
linear model so i don't believe i'm not
sure if it's disparity or the way the
noise
interacts with the signal
all right thanks everybody for those
questions i guess it's probably time to
wrap
up for super brightest talk so thanks
again super brata and